okay hi everyone we are doing awesome
language design review of a new function
called text summarize
which is a function that has been
proposed multiple times over the last 20
years and I think now thanks to llms it
finally becomes realistic to make a
reasonable version of it
so uh how do I run it can I run it yeah
if you've always emit code just the
whole cell
okay so if I run this am I going to get
the same answer every time
well maybe Plumbing usual and stuff the
the temperature is quite low but it's
not zero as it's recommended
summarizing text piece what the heck is
a text piece yeah we can uh we can I
mean this is all uh uh temporary text
basically this is splitting the text
into chunks and so if it has multiple
chunks
be a computer wide and say one out of
one just just put these yes yes it is
only one I have to I have to to just
skip that part
blah blah
yes yeah right
yeah I I just need need to say why don't
we say
text Chunk
one of three right I believe that's
consistent with what we do elsewhere
okay yeah
okay
Okay so
I expected a bit with prompts what's
that yeah yeah I I explained it a bit
with prompts
um you were last time you suggested to
have something that doesn't sound much
like it's like third person
so if you say summary and I believe it's
probably is in this agenda if you scroll
down there's one that has the same tone
as this oh you don't have one okay so
you can you can you can try you oh
actually it is in there it doesn't look
like an extract this looks like multiple
extracts
well extract is
sentences from the so then call it
extracts if that's what it is
uh okay sorry that's because I'm not
native speaker I thought it was a
correct definition of extract sentences
from the from the text okay no they're
separately quoted there are multiple
extracts plural
okay if it was in one quotation mark
which wouldn't be right this is better
well actually this should be a list of
sentences but uh that's also some of the
um when I'm when I finalize the prompts
I have to figure out why sometimes it
works sometimes it doesn't that is uh it
should like stuff like keywords and
extracts should be a list because you
you ask for list of sentences or list of
keywords
um I need to kind of Bulletproof the the
fuzziness of the llm output and make
sure that the in every case I don't
think that the default should say the
text provides
exactly you you mentioned this last time
if you scroll down the ref page notebook
I have added the ease in the ref page
for the Declaration of Independence
I've added another one which is called
um summary yeah we should discuss all
these names because I'm quite bad one is
is a paraphrase abstract in says the
text blah blah blah and summary actually
keeps the same tone so we I put it in
scope so you can compare the the the the
differences between uh but that should
be the default for example the summary
yeah yeah I I guess we I left so what is
this
which one the one the the one that is
the default right now
the wireless is abstract I've
implemented
no no yeah I I will switch it
the same the text is
by the way this is not the right format
right we have colons and things here for
goodness sake let's make this no no I'm
using the default I'm using the default
uh the the only thing that is is
customized text
if you scroll down you see it in the in
the left Page you see the result without
the these text provides blah blah blah
uh is in scope where I use the same
input for all of them
so yeah this is one using this text and
this one here you see this one keeps the
same in the same style
if I want a different sum if I want a
shorter summary
yeah I'm I'm playing prompt engineering
you see we have this method compression
medium
uh we can package it in in some ways but
uh it's a delicate thing because you
need to describe to the llm how you you
want it long
so I I'm kind of experimenting with this
compression level and I don't think it
should be too fine-grained something
like uh uh high medium and low or
something like that
um
because you could try specifying the
number of lines but uh it probably won't
work it ignores it if it doesn't
understand that sometimes it works
sometimes it doesn't for some number it
might work for some number it might not
so I think it's just that promise that
we cannot really keep if you put like a
specific specific number of characters
or lines
well I mean we could enforce it and we
could send it back to the llm and say
it's wrong
yeah I'm always hesitant to do those
things that can possibly involve an
infinite iteration with the llm
yeah and also you know the llm is going
to get better at doing those kinds of
things and we don't want to design
that
you know
I I mean I do believe that's the type of
thing that will actually improve many
things will not improve much but that
will
true but we can I mean if we have a
setting which is which has like discrete
intervals then we can switch it to a
continuous interval like zero to one
with the with not not much effort if if
we notice that it got improved
um
all right
you know I mean I'm thinking about what
this would say if it didn't say the text
is
did you see the one the one that they
have in in school but that's for cats
and this isn't no no no no no I have e
in summary so in scope if you scroll
down to scope I have a summary for the
Declaration of Independence
there the second one you see the the
comparison
okay do other people have comments on
this please
I'm I'm concerned that that
in some situations
you want
a description the text is
do you see what I'm saying in some cases
you want an actual summary we have lots
of other people on school so somebody
else speak up here please
anybody else have an opinion or not I
mean I think that the thought you want
is
a summary and that the abstract version
is should be something where you're
asking for abstract I agree with which
one is something the summary the text is
what is the summary in the course of
human events
I think the sum the second one is closer
to this I mean the summary it's got a
little bit too much abstract in it in
this version
if you get me yeah
um
you want it to be higher level rather
than trying to actually use the language
so I don't think it's supposed to be in
the style it's going to probably use
some of the language
yeah I did several experiments it was
difficult to fine-tune because I also
didn't have the super clear idea about
what it is to keep short but also keep
the style and the Persona the the text
and the one that's listening or summary
looks me more like X you know it's
extracts
um
reduce it's reduced by but it's all
extract nature
hopefully it should be verbatim this one
is free to to change but maybe free to
change but it's not changing very much
let's look at the design that you're
proposing here yeah okay okay first
point is where's the source text okay
Source text fine it's
yeah those seem fine
list of objects so it's going to produce
a single summary of the list of objects
yes
okay
look so here we we have everything that
I mean text summarize generates a
textual summary
you know
generates this summarized form of
a piece of text or something I mean in I
don't know
okay let's go down to this
okay we have one I mean at least I have
one way okay The Prompt is something go
ahead what were you saying uh about
about the um like stain stain with
um uh with the with the input
um so one thing that this could digest
is a vector database
and the solutions is using that
databases to for this specific problem
um
okay so in you see that the third usage
line I say topic goes to spec
yes and this is a way to kind of
pinpoint you know have you have a lot of
material you don't want uh like extracts
or a summary of everything you just just
want about the stock about the White
Rabbit in in Alice in Wonderland you
don't care about the rest so that's it
extremely useful uh because you don't
understand syntax is crazy because you
might just want a summarization of that
topic of the text so I strongly suggest
let's start doing it that way that the
thing to do would be to say text
summarize
of text Arrow topic or something comma
spec
no okay
yeah because that way you you don't if
you don't give the spec you don't have
to worry about it
yeah
makes sense
so then that form without this without
the second argument
is going to be a default version of
where did I put it where am I putting
this guys
and you're gonna you're gonna put it
somewhere the right place that's fine
okay I'm sorry go ahead okay so the
thing is
um if you have a lot of text the default
state of the art
is instead of doing something like our
text search which is a query based
like based on on the on the actual
strings uh like bag of words and stuff
like that is to embed
like all pieces of this obviously and
then and then do matching with like with
the detective database so uh my proposal
would be to kind of uh for this like
release these now as it is because it's
very useful and if you have an external
back to database you can still use a
list of of strings syntax and
immediately use this function and then
work to support the vector database in
some format you know what one
possibility would be to integrate it uh
in text search you know have a different
back end for text search I would like to
have it like something available
language wise uh yeah not something
inside Tech summarize because it sounds
like a broader thing uh
but yeah this requires something like we
discussed like fuzzy
um Vector uh nearest neighbor like
something that you don't have in nearest
so like there's a bit of technology to
be implemented first
so yeah this I think is kind of a
separate design I mean there are a bunch
of helper functions here because what
you're basically saying is take a piece
of text and is it sentence by sentence
or what where what what chunk is
embedded
as much as your llm can handle no no no
no no I'm asking you're saying that if
you want to find
the topic
a particular topic for the topic one
sorry yeah yeah sorry for the topic uh
yeah I guess the the granularity if you
want it very granular uh maybe Jason you
you had I mean your team has some
experience with that we did
we did Page by page because the LM can
happily read a whole page and find the
things on it so
um so then you're homing in on pages
and you're then going to
yeah typically several prompt so wait a
minute what you're doing is
you've got a thousand page document
only 10 pages have everything even
vaguely relevant
so you're using the embedding Vector
database story to you know to prune it
down to 10 pages and then you're using
prompting to say on those 10 pages tell
me about this topic is that correct
basically correct and we have a
parameter for how many uh things you
wanted to retrieve often it three or
sometimes it's five or young it can be
as many as 10 but it's not determined
it's not uh determined by the topic that
if there's anything relevant on those
pages it's instead there's a fixed
maximum number of the most relevant
pages from highest at least most
relevant to least relevant and it reads
that number of pages and summarizes the
subject based upon what I saw on those
pages
okay but hold on hold on so if you you
read the top three pages the top five
page you're reading the top three pages
the top five pages the top ten Pages
depending on how it was called right
what what second argument is given what
was called uh that's the number of
things that the llm reads and then if
it's the prompt engineering is that
having read these you know answer the
user's question about this topic
um and that's what yeah
but I mean so so
at a lower level
what we potentially want
is
you know something like this
right we want something which says and
this would give us
somehow I don't know quite what the
right return is but some kind of thing
which is some sort of list that is these
vectors are associated with these chunks
of text
I mean it's very similar to the to the
um
text search index objects search index
object yeah and this is why it's
futurized in the text possibilities
I I I don't know how Nick feels about
that we just discussed that a bit but uh
I would like to explore the idea of
making this a method
around that functional search index
object well I mean yeah I mean right now
it's just lucene yeah but I know I have
to see yeah
just spent months making this work for
for embedding so maybe he can say
something here
so swastikas is here too but I'm here as
well I can speak to this so uh what
swastik was doing for embeddings related
search was uh it's not tied into text
search though it certainly could be the
uh you know why not
why isn't it tied into Tech search yet
it's it's on our roadmap it's just you
know we're trying to get the you know
we're trying to make it work first
before you know messing with established
functionality there's no reason that it
can't be tied into Tech search I mean
obviously that has to be designed and
that's what we're talking about what's
up I said as a method option exactly
yeah I mean there are a lot of pieces to
that like talking about where to store
the vectors and things like that but you
know that's kind of what we're here to
talk about right but that can be part of
the
search index object can it not
sure
I would think so yeah well it can be in
memory or or out of core and on this
giving it should probably be out of core
but yeah these are technicalities I mean
we should be able to handle that
was Excellence yep
okay
but
so the idea is to somehow have that be
called so the actual thing that will be
called here is you would do this
so you would be saying essentially
you're saying I don't do this I say
create search index
of the text method Arrow
whatever it is text embedding
all right and that will generate a
search index object
and then that
will
that that's the thing that's happening
inside text summarize is that correct
well you know if you can if you provide
a search index object as an argument I I
think it's better to keep this in two
steps because this is
okay I understand that but can we tell
if
you know if you just gave it a random
search index object that wasn't
connected to that text does the search
index object have enough tagging in it
to know what the text actually is
uh no I mean there is no text you you
give a search in that object in place of
text I I assumed that that stands for
what I see does that work
Brian or swastik does that work does the
search index object contain the text it
would have to it does not contain the
full text it can't otherwise it would be
you know our the search index object for
our docs would be the size of the docs
plus well it probably is
like 20 Megs
usually the indices in an index is about
the same size as the text
nobody I mean if this is out of core it
just matter it has to point to some
database when the text is
so this would make everything extremely
light
yeah I understand I understand but
that's not the architecture right now
for search index object is it
or is it can somebody just say that
please
search index object here he's the one
who's supposed to be working on this
no okay well he was invited but yeah
search index object is uh it can
certainly live without the Corp without
the doc's Corpus in the same place right
you don't need and we that's how we ship
our product right there's a there's a
full index goes with the product but not
the full docs so you don't need it it's
not just a list of pointers pointing to
the text
it is self-contained
now you can certainly you know Tech
search and create search index and
things like that you can make it such
that there is a field in the index that
contains the entire plain text you know
it's it's extensible in that way uh
that's not how I don't think that's the
default
are you still there uh yep okay
and this is still different from how the
vector database formula this works
obviously I mean uh in that you you do
have all the information in the original
text but you've encoded it differently
you've already passed it through a you
know um an embedding layer and uh
because most of those vectors are sparse
they can be
um handled um relatively efficiently but
you haven't thrown away any of the
information
right okay well so there is the question
of you know it creates or sorry create
search index and search index object are
on disk those represent you know out of
core indices is do we want text
summarize to be able to work on you know
you just throw a piece of text at it and
it works in memory
hell yeah because if so then you know
it's it's something a little higher
level than create things with X or
search index objects
yeah like Tech summarize just sees the
text but the text can be fed by
different uh actors yeah okay so in this
case the the session in index object is
just the the DJ I mean you ask for the
topic yeah and then that provides you
with the with the right piece of text
either with the texture database I mean
we could even hook it up as it is now
using the scene
to still fit in the same design
but you still want
you you just want your design to be that
by the time your actual Tech summarize
function sees it it's already been
turned into
um relevant pieces of text
yeah exactly but this this can be done
by the current text search as well yeah
like it's uh sure is maybe less powerful
than uh than llm on the whole pipeline
uh but right yes all right so let's just
go through the design here so I mean
this question of if you already have a
search index object what do you do is a
separate question from making this work
for a you know fairly small piece of
text couple of pages you know all in
memory etc etc et cetera right
yeah
okay so this is
I mean
to what extent is that topic thing a you
know a question
you know can this were the British
rotors
is that what this is supposed to be well
that's Declaration of Independence or
something
or what what is that supposed to be and
how is it going to be prompted
I mean I don't have a definite answer to
this because I think that this is mostly
what we want it to be in in my mind this
was the uh what and how
the the topic and the uh and the fine
textual answer already has this
mechanism
for
you know ask a question text comma
question
um
right so I think that's a different
thing than this
and perhaps the prompting you know a
text here what about um I don't know
taxes
yeah this is a lot more how I see it
yeah okay fine but then find textual
answer can use the same technology
oh yeah to pinpoint him in a topic
before asking the question yes for
example
yeah
they should be parallel but they're
mostly differ in what they return
whether or not you want an actual answer
whether or not you want a longer summary
that can be taken from more parts of the
text yeah
also one thing that we discussed briefly
when I started looking at these four
possible extension using llms this
design is very tight on the answer that
is in the text okay so if there is no
see that word there experimental
okay yes I I've been I've been told that
that is tough experimental is being
experienced for too long we need to
maintain background but this one is so
bad honestly yes but I don't think
there's a a problem you know I I don't I
think it you know I think we should just
change it
you know sorry a new technology came
along we can do something better now
okay we can come up with them with the
with the new proposal for this
uh
now
some of this is still useful and will be
good to try to get out of the llm
exactly exactly I think we can still ask
the LM to provide some context about and
this would be the main difference in
fine textual answer you know like I
cannot provide Syntax for work out to
have this be an arbitrary prompt
I find that very hard to believe don't
we have a rapper
the what
uh you mean LM prompt well this one
because that interacts to the Repository
you can use string templates if you want
or template object
that's all the stuff that's supported by
LM function
so I can disable the I mean right now
all the strings that are not not
explicit specification they're
interpreted as uh yeah I think One's
Gonna Want anywhere string template
because I don't see how you can do this
without you know it's got to be applied
to the text yeah yeah it makes sense
again we can just drop like the text if
not doing anything then that's directly
every prompt I have is applied to the
text so
yeah but if it doesn't it's just a it's
a text summary exactly which is the
Guardians of the Galaxy it just says
grouped
which is no actually is is funny because
um
uh I forgot actually to hook up the the
the argument and
um so if you do like I don't know llm
synthetize and you say title which would
be the same thing yeah as doing this
without the text you actually get a
title for something
it's kind of this LM hallucination I
don't know if you've ever played with
that so you can say title summary and it
gives you something or even empty string
and it gives you something back oh it
tells you some kind of title for it yeah
if you see LM synthetized title
then you get a title
great
magnificent I thought you knew this this
is the type of thing that you like
foreign
before
it's like you had that one before yeah
impact on social media mental health
yeah
ah what's the world coming to
try empty string
I assume these guys have
kind of dealt with these Corner cases
what's going to do is it going to write
is it going to write a speech is there a
right it's not right stuff yeah
stories or things
should still be
you know
checked by the all the alignment policy
so it shouldn't be too bad
well at least it's writing about itself
it's kind of like like lots of humans oh
this this is random this is run I got
like not related to AI trying it's other
times like stories or things
sometimes very specific
well sorry I distracted you we shouldn't
be doing this
um
okay in any case
yeah
it's the dreaming llm
okay let's come back to this
okay so the question is if you say text
summarize of a piece of text
I think this is a reasonable Syntax for
giving a topic
now the question is what on Earth should
the spec really be
okay so I claim this isn't right that
that well I don't know I don't know how
to you know okay an abstract
I don't know most abstracts just start
off I mean they say things like we show
that
uh
AI will not destroy the world or
something
says that AI what's that that's from
papers but yeah what's the episode of
the Wikipedia I mean it doesn't say we
we show no I I don't know just the
summary so that's a good that's a good
example if it's the um like
I don't think you know a summary is a
summary that's the type of thing you see
at the top of Wikipedia an abstract is a
different kind of thing isn't it I mean
okay do we have anybody who's kind of
uh knows about the kind of uh we have
the wrong group of people for this the
kind of English literature angle and all
of this
do you want me to see if Michael or
Allen are around
Alan might be a good person for this
okay alternatively
um
uh
um maybe Mark long
I can check it with Mark
um
I think that's what we need here because
I don't really know what this how Okay
so keywords
by the way this text you can't say in
one of them verb paraphrase blah blah
another short version of
see what I'm saying
paraphrasing of text whatever if it's uh
okay okay yeah sorry I see the style
yeah
okay
I mean you know we could if we wanted to
be cute we could say tldr and things
like that
but I think we don't want to be cute
we also have we also we also have the um
from proposal yeah I know
so we could have LM prompt tldr
yes which is fine
which is yeah
one line or something
yeah I mean this is more like a
suggestion uh I feel very uncomfortable
doing this because this is not my
language and uh I'm kind of I
I tried to read the the stock exchange
for English about the differences
between abstract synopsis summary
there seems to be a lot of synonyms here
so
the the fine details are really lost on
me yeah
right I mean one common way to add one
another additional potential thing could
be like an itemized list if we are
thinking of adding things here otherwise
no it's not that can be handled through
the prompting
yeah why not I mean
itemized or something or something like
that yeah being a bulleted list is a
nice idea exactly sorry my bad Ankara
really suggested that I forgot to add it
here
okay
yep all right let's we have Mark joined
us okay here's the context we're looking
at a function called text summarize
which summarizes text using an alarm uh
what we want to talk about is
and kind of
English writing usage
the difference between an abstract a
summary
a I don't know what else you call it I
mean the the kind of the way you write
an abstract
Mark do you have a do you have something
you can say about what
what how would you characterize the
difference between a summary and an
abstract
well a summary would actually cover all
the texts or all the content that was in
there in a concise manner and Abstract
is more like an executive summary in
technical writing which basically hits
on what your thesis or point of
Investigation is along with your
terminal conclusions but the summary
would have everything in between too in
terms of all the evidence and line of
logic
okay
so okay so that difference in usage is
an abstract is what's the main point and
a summary attempts to
cover everything in some way so for
example
an abstract which we have here maybe of
the Declaration of Independence
would be
kind of
you know wherever it is somewhere down
here
um
okay I don't know that's a reasonable
abstract a difference in the summary I
mean this is okay the other problem is
under what circumstances
should we be saying the text is how
would you characterize
the difference between something that
says the text is blah blah blah
versus
in the course of human events blah blah
blah
so I'm saying one is a descriptive
is about the text a summary of the text
from the outside saying this text is
and the other is a summary kind of from
the inside that just says this is what
we're saying
right
um
well the Declaration of Independence is
written in first person plural but I
wouldn't necessarily write a summary
like that though
yeah
well I mean I just think that the
summary in essence everything that's in
your abstract is in your summary it's
just that your summary will address
every single section A major point of
evidence we've only got let's say we've
got three sentences you're gonna fit
whatever you've got to fit in three
sentences
we're pegged on the length let's say
foreign
so then I mean you don't get to you know
if you have a thousand page book
we still have a you know four sentence
summary or something
and whatever it is similar length
abstract so if you know we've got to be
able to Define what's the difference I
mean
okay so if you were talking about a book
uh the abstract would be the point that
the book makes the summary would be the
narrative structure of the book
okay I mean in a general sense
okay all right so then but in that
distinction okay which hopefully is
understood by the llm that distinction
I think there's a good chance you will
understand that
so then the question would be
um
uh
in you know which one of these or is it
a different thing entirely says
descriptively like a review this book is
garbage
as opposed to
um
another one which would say
you know we should just launch and say
what it has to say
what were you a review would be
different than a summary or an abstract
no I understand but but you understand
the difference the distinction I'm
making does it start this text is
or does it just launch into
uh you know I mean this is a very good
launch Point here but but you know
even
even just take off the words in this
text and just start the representative
of the United States blah blah blah
yeah okay but what is the what is the
thing
that starts in this text blah blah blah
like a book review would say in this
book blah blah
how do you what do you call that as
distinct from a summary or an abstract
I would call it a description but
okay
Mark do you have any comments on that I
mean it's some kind of description
review something
well I would say that a summary starts
with the beginning of the book
or the article where I would say an
abstract would almost start with your
conclusion because uh executive
summaries which is kind of like an
abstract start with your conclusion so
that people know exactly what the whole
thing is about
okay so wait a minute you'll make your
distinction between an executive summary
and a summary
well technically yes in terms of writing
technical reports that begin with uh
executive summary which is different
than just like a book report summary
executive summary tells you
what the the con it actually tells you
what the conclusions of the paper are so
and I'd say that's an ABS that's an
Essence an abstract
okay but so you're you're claiming
executive summary and Abstract are
should they be considered synonymous or
are they
should they be distinguished
I would use them as synonyms almost but
I would differentiate between a summary
because a summary is like a book report
that just walks through step by step
from the beginning I mean we're relying
on the llm understanding these
distinctions which I think it will but
I'm coming back again to my question
does it say in this text or in this book
blah blah blah or does it simply launch
into you know uh
you know the summary is
um you know cats are wonderful animals
or something
does it say in this text
I don't think it has to no no I
understand but I'm asking is there a
form in which well first first question
for folks like Jason and so on is it
useful to have something that says in
this text or is that always just fluff
I mean I think it's mostly fluff but if
you specifically asked for a description
you want somebody describing it from the
outside they can see wanting that um
but it's it's a specialized use it's not
the usual case the usual cases you want
it to as you put it launch with the
subject matter itself in in the long
summary form or in the short abstract
form
um
but uh
from outside would be description but by
the way I mean in in this thing like
short summary you know that that's not a
bad way for us to name these things
instead of that whole you know thing
with short long whatever whatever I mean
we could just say
you know short summary long summary
short abstract long abstract what do you
think Julio
yes yeah possible possible yeah even
easier more like more clear less obscure
right so also because some of those they
are like
inherently I mean they have a length
already like you know the the like title
has is is one sentence so we've got
we've got title
we've got
um
uh
of their
you know keywords will be roughly in
order of their importance
um well we can ask right now it is in
order of the like how the text reads so
I depends on on what you want okay so I
think that's also has a usefulness
because you you just can basically
imagine what the text is about by just
reading the keywords
that would be like a keyword summary
okay
like keywords would be just the list of
keywords
I think you know if the if the thing
starts with cats and ends with dogs but
there's a lot more about dogs in it I
would argue you should put dogs first in
the list of keywords
there's um see what I'm saying yep yep I
know where the keyword summary is the
right term but that would be keywords
that are you know kind of
uh sort of you know
does it make sense to have a a version
of that function which would have like
frequences actually so it's already
ready for like word cloud
keyword and score something like this
or scored keywords something like that
so that you have a list of them with a a
keyword score pair that's suitable for
people oh yeah yeah sorry it was in the
string suggestion it was uh yeah yeah
so in this case we would have like a
list of rules as an output or something
like that maybe maybe I'm a little bit
concerned about outperforms that aren't
the same
okay so you you would like for all of
these to be a single string
well actually that's not realistic
because some of these are lists so I I
take that back I'm retracting that
statement that means this would be
possible to have scored keywords that
are different
yeah this is something that really I
envisioned it will require like most of
my time to make sure that the outputs
can be coheres in the into the right uh
into the right shape because anyway so
okay so fine so back up here
I mean we could also say
you know given that we're having short
long summary we're going to say one line
summary
which might be different from short
summary I don't really know
but um uh okay
so what would we call okay so you
suggested itemized list
but I mean I don't know what what is
that called is there some better term
than bullet list
Mark anybody
on call who suggested this anybody else
I mean bullet list highlighted list um
highlights
um
this could be
one of the most useful things because
you can if you can have highlights with
a number right
I want that I want five bullet things or
no more than five bullet things
to do prompt engineering but if you can
ask for it to be summarized at this mini
bullet points so right so I mean so if
we say numbered items
if they're numbered I mean I don't know
do you actually want the number in the
text
I don't particularly isn't I don't
really need a number of the texts the
main thing is that you can coerce it to
have only the number of things but we
don't have a mechanism for that and what
we've been describing so far
so unless we have
a unless what we do is we say that this
thing says text summarize
of
you know again the syntax will be text
or some
way of specifying text possibly text
Arrow topic
and then here
[Music]
um
you know spec
or potentially we could do spec
Arrow size or something
you see what I'm saying
um
and that could be
see I don't know I mean what we could do
there is Say by default an N which is
sentences
and we could have a quantity object
there
you know quantity you know whatever it
is 10 words a hundred words or something
and the llm is not going to behave
itself every time
why didn't that work
I thought that was a valid unit
what the heck okay there's a bug there
somebody report that please
yeah I can do that
okay
so you know there is a unit there people
understand what I'm saying so so you
could say a spec
like
abstract for example Arrow 200 words
that make sense
yeah
related question is uh can you have a
list for off topic and you have it like
three topics two topics why not
yep
I mean and it's going to
what it means by that is I want stuff in
the text about either Elephants or
walruses
it's not like I want only the section
that's about elephants dancing with
walruses
correct if you give two or you want to
give it no no no no no no no no you've
got to decide what what it means if you
give two right I think we had done in
the past at least was and an alternative
was or
well that's for some things but I don't
know whether that that doesn't seem to
make a lot of sense to me here yeah
especially because your your actual
topic there isn't forced to be something
Atomic right you could have your
individual
topic be something which is a where do
your thing that says you know only
dancing with
yes
um
okay
I mean by the way Sanders pointed out on
a live stream what about things like you
know passive voice formula etc etc those
are things where you've got to be able
to add in the prompt right those are
those are modifiers effectively
but you should be able to do
the modifier prompts
uh okay so you want you want to chain
The Prompt with the with the
specification
right I'm asking for the Syntax for a
modifier yeah
what is the modifier what is the way you
do a modifier prompt in alarm synthesize
yeah they're all they are chained if you
put a list of them they're chained
together
I see
so you could say a lamp prompt uh
passive voice right so that means the
spec here
which you're saying could be either
abstract blah blah blah so so what it
would look like is
it will be this
and then it would say
abstract comma
uh llm prompt
formal
right yeah
and I mean there's a courtesy we might
try to look up the strings I don't know
if that's a good idea
yeah we make timer hands there like it's
very clear if you use it through a learn
prompt
yes
I'm thinking there's another another
possible usage for daily syntax but uh
it would you know supporting multiple
specs than returning like a Association
of those
still involves separate calls so I don't
see any immediate benefits over right so
uh flask on a live stream comments that
the executive summary should be
something capable of being read on its
own which I would agree with
so this should be something that's
capable of being read on its own you
don't need the document there obviously
oh okay so it protect summarize in
general the whole point is Give me a
summary so I don't have to read the
document I mean the tldr story
um
okay all right what else do we have to
figure out here I think we've made some
progress in defining
this what else do we do we need to work
out
well this is a really sizable amount of
stuff to update so I I think it's it's a
good very good direction for for this
function the only question I suppose
would be
all the you know people gonna understand
summary versus abstract and we're going
to have to say in the documentation some
some summary of what we've been saying
here
namely the summary carries the whole
narrative the abstract is only The
Punchy part
so to speak
is only the you know what the point is
supposed to be summary slash abstract
slash executive summary
is what the takeaway should be not what
the narrative structure is or what the
supporting you know the fact that it has
it'll just say you know walruses are the
best animals in the Arctic
that's the executive summary
and the summary might be
uh you know
a study is done of all the different
kinds of animals in the Arctic and it is
concluded that you know walruses are the
best because polar bears
you know
don't
aren't capable of doing this or that or
whatever it is does that make sense to
people
yes not the part about the polar bears
which is irrelevant but but um the um
but that distinction
you know I think it was Mark who brought
up description and I like you know I
like description as maybe something
different you know if you threw the
Declaration of Independence at it
wouldn't it be nice if it could tell you
this is the Declaration of Independence
this is you know this were these were
the ramifications of this document it
was written in blah blah blah well yeah
but that's asking it that's asking for
the llm to make random stuff up yeah all
the information needs to be in the text
isn't such a bad thing that would be
this text is blah blah blah right yeah
I mean in in the use case where you're
just feeding it like top three or five
pages right I don't see description
being a very useful thing
I don't agree with you think about a
corporate setting where
you know you've got a bunch of documents
and it's like
this document
is
you know it's something says this
document is a thing sent to the HR
department complaining about this type
thing right as opposed to
uh
you know Joe said the plant in his
office was trying to eat him
right which would be a different you see
what I'm saying
yeah I think the description the
description use does make sense there I
think the thing on course trying to get
at is if you're already feeding it only
extracts it
um uh it may not be able to do the
descriptive summary of the whole thing
well then that's but that's the whole
point it's this is what a super function
does is if you if it if you're asking it
for the description it's going to find
what it needs to find
yeah but I do like the idea of breaking
out the concept of a description which
is the meta thing saying this text is
the Declaration of Independence or
whatever as opposed yeah I agree
you know getting into the meat of it
uh
now I mean let's just think about use
cases here because
you know for example let's say I've got
email coming in a whole bunch of email
coming in
actually description might not be a bad
thing to ask for
you know this is a piece of mail from
somebody who wants to invest in a
company
this is a piece of mail from somebody
who's trying to sell us something this
is a piece of mail from somebody who's
trying to buy something from us
sure and you can definitely imagine
using that for sorting and so forth
before you even look at the summaries
right
and then
I mean for summaries you know we know
we're already using something and I
assume we know what the prompting is for
that uh the summaries we're using for
the uh digest of llm
uh preprints
that Michael is generating Julio do you
know what the prompts are for that
no not really I'll ask
um you know what I'm talking about
though right you see these every day
yeah
and they're quite good in my opinion
right I mean
I don't know I mean I try to read them
yeah no no not all of them but yeah
I mean let me pull one up
uh
let's see
um
okay here we go
so
this is the actual
summer abstract from the paper
oh wow so that is probably a a generated
keyword list
notice also this Fields list here
that's by a categorization
yeah I would click tags but yeah
is
go ahead they're a bit more
computational than just keywords because
they're they're not
record tags they're taken from something
like a um uh structure of science I
would count on that they're taking from
anything actually I mean this
but I do like this this concept here
um
okay in any case the so go find out from
Michael how he's generating these things
because I mean clearly this
this thing that we're getting here
uh and I I know
you know in generating these summaries
we're going from a PDF I think
I'm making sense
yes
so that's the thing that you've got to
know how to do and I don't know you know
I assume it's stripping all kinds of
stuff with with uh formulas and so on
that it can't handle I don't know
whether we're importing
can we import PDF as text I thought we
could we can yeah we can we can that's
ideally that's just really stripping
everything that is not text
or making a text
right
um
okay
well anything else to go over in this
meeting
uh maybe one thing is like I put this
property argument here I'm not sure if
this is super useful the only two I
couldn't think of is I mean it was to
access like the thing is if the stuff is
too big for the context you need to
iterate
well are you interested in property
worst property uh possible values for
prop r just above the options
where is the property where does it get
put in
that he's he's just a third argument
I see
it's I mean I put the there initially
because I
um I was understanding I realized we
didn't have any
sorry no worrying about chunking
yeah I mean what if you want to get the
intermediate results also for like kind
of understanding what's going on and
maybe fine-tune your prompts or stuff
like that
well I mean maybe
that should be just a thing here that
you only use if you're trying to debug
that's called text chunks
see what I'm saying I mean in the in the
things you can ask for
don't actually summarize just give me a
list of text chunks
not sure how useful that is I mean
that's just going to depend on you know
it's various lln ergonomics of how big
the chunks are oh no no no no sorry
misunderstanding here the thing is if
you ask for a summary
and you have a very long piece of text
you need to summarize the chunks and
then summarize the summaries I
understand
but if this chunks are separately
summarized you can ask for text chunks
and then map text Maps text oh okay I
see your board yeah yeah yeah
I mean if you really want to know what's
going on
I mean I predict that we're not going to
do it that way and I predict that it's
going to be more sophisticated than that
very quickly and that we're not
independently going to summarize every
chunk and then summarize the summary so
to speak that's just kind of a hopefully
should be a fallback case if you put in
a very big string and you are not using
any any search or topic topic like
symptoms yeah I understand so that means
that this kind of debug Escape valve
seems worth having
but not
super highlighted like as taking a whole
argument yeah yeah right makes sense
because I mean it it's because most of
the time you're not going to want that
okay does anybody else have any other
thoughts about things that will be
you know immediately useful I mean I
really you know this description thing
is a really good idea relative to
summary and abstract and so on because
it really is a different thing
so what other use cases
uh
you know what we've got
I mean in the case of the you know the
the daily llm abstracts
is very clearly I just want to know what
the heck these papers are about
it's a very clear point and I don't want
the description would be this is a paper
that does blah blah blah I don't want to
know that they're all papers
right so what doesn't what are other use
cases Json on car anybody
I mean I think that the use cases that
we want in Solutions are going to be
covered by this design I don't see other
things missing I can think of some um
neat example
to make using it after you know the
whole thing is working
um one of the ones we've had is use the
tech summarize with bullet points with
questions to automatically generate a
slideshow right
um so those sorts of things we you know
do some notebook programming Downstream
of this
um so you can sort of automatic document
generated generation of the slideshow of
what was our use case uh all the legal
proceedings that a company is going
through in a particular quarter for
example yeah
but so for that
it's the same kind of text summarize
with a question
or a set of questions
um and you want to be able to do it as
bullet points we control the bullets you
are something specific there with
numbered items and what you're now
saying is
you actually want something if you want
to put it on multiple slides
I doubt you want one cent I mean first
of all you do not want the stupid
numbers embedded in the I don't want the
numbers the usual case we had was
um you're asking for each specific
question right you're getting the five
you know three to yeah five bullet point
answers and then that goes on a slide
with the question at the essay title of
the slide and the answer is as the
bullets on the side
let's be clear on what you want for the
bulleted items do you want a list of
items or do you want the thing where the
text says one blah blah blah new line
two blah blah yeah it doesn't I don't
want to say one one two I just want it
to be the you know bulleted uh items yes
you want it to be a list of items you
want it to be a list which is a bunch of
sentences so let's see what the name of
that should be
okay what should the name of that be
it's definitely not highlighted items
that's definitely not it
it's not numbered items because that
suggests there's a number there
I mean it's an app ordered list
what is it bulleted list I don't know
because that might suggest there are
bullets there does Mark have a
suggestion or anybody else
what would you call
the one two three I know how to list
versus other list are used in HTML
if we want to be what about topic list
if not topics
yeah he has a different thing that's
categories
which is a different thing that that
might be that's the thing
categories
or and or topics are yet more different
things you might ask for I mean this is
something we've asked we've thought
about for a long time topic modeling we
you know considered that like 15 years
ago we didn't do it because we thought
that the target was too mushy
okay so what is the name that you give
the you know what is the thing that I
mean is it called a bulleted list except
that doesn't have bullets what do you
call it
itemized list
yeah our bullet items
well you're describing the whole thing
so bullet items would be well
maybe itemized lust is the best thing
for right now
hey Mark yes you're the most likely
person to come up with them for this
what would you call this
you know to be honest I think itemized
list is about as good as I mean
that works for me
is there a term for it in you know
official technical writing-ish type
stuff
not really I mean basically in technical
writing you're gonna have bulleted lists
or numbered lists numbered lists are
used for a sequence bullet list or just
used for unordered items and that's
about as
the biggest amount of structure you're
going to get between those
okay
um
yeah here's kind of a different thing
would we care about
like year or any like time like when was
this written or about what time period
is this written or is that two well it's
a different esoteric
different thing I mean really
summarize go ahead
I say we do care about it but it's
usually a fine textual answer is kind of
separate question about the document
right it's not part of the summary let
me
right
sounds good okay anything else to cover
here
oh
okay
thank you very much the comments thank
you all here okay